Ashton Kutcher first became a household
name thanks to his breakthrough role at
the lovable doofus Michael Kelso on the
hit sitcom that 70s show but he's also
attempted to gain some traction on the
big stream with mixed results lately
Kutcher his movie roles have seen fewer
and farther in between with that in mind
here are some theories as to why
Hollywood doesn't have much room for him
at the box office anymore small screen
starts viewers might have been split
between team Kelso and team Hyde when it
came to Jackie's love life throughout
that 70 show the Kutcher's on-screen
presences the jovial bonehead simply
could not be denied the show catapulted
has been 21 year olds into instant fame
and he went on to solidify his status as
a small screen A lister by co-creating
MTV Frank show Punk'd where his rolodex
full of famous people came in handy as
he pulled practical jokes on all his new
Hollywood pals he even single-handedly
brought mesh trucker hats back into
style which is no easy feat dude where's
my blockbuster Kutcher did have some
initial success translating a slapstick
humor to the big screen in 2000 dude
where's my car and he charmed alongside
Brady Murphy in 2003 is just married but
both films still earn scathing reviews
that didn't exactly bolster his rep as a
serious actor no no one Ben no one no
one no as it could sure tried to turn
things around with a starring role in
2004 time-travel thriller the butterfly
effect while the movie made a nice chunk
of change his Rotten Tomatoes average
wasn't exactly improved as a result of
the arguably under a flick collectively
Kutcher filmography has been marred with
one pan after another from reviewers
another movies he's acted in has ever
broken the 50% threshold in their Rotten
Tomatoes score
and you got me there that's major burn
total typecast Summa Kutcher's biggest
commercial successes on the silver
screen have remained in the comedic
realm including his 2008 rom-com with
Cameron Diaz what happens in Vegas his
part in Garry Marshalls 2010 ensemble
drama D Valentine's Day and his friends
with benefits film with Natalie Portman
2011 s no strings attached in each of
those movies Kutcher's quirky demeanor
helped his character stick and although
none of them were as dim-witted as
Michael Kelso or his dude persona Jesse
Montgomery the third they also weren't
exactly Mensa material but simply his
fans seemed to prefer when Kutcher
sticks to the most basic levels of
intelligence on print his lead role in
2013's jobs a much hyped Steve Jobs
biopic failed to resonate with audiences
or critics as well
proving that without the laughs no one's
really interested costly comeback as the
still momentum slowed Kutcher made what
was poised to be a winning return to
television in 2011 replacing Charlie
Sheen on Two and a Half Men despite the
fact that Kutcher seemed like an ideal
addition to the show which boasted
sky-high viewership during gaemes tenure
ratings rapidly declined after that he
again returned to TV with the Netflix
that come the ranch in 2016 on paper the
ranch had all the right ingredients for
small screen success up to and including
his old screen partner from that 70 show
Danny Masterson and a roundtable cameo
from fellow former cast mate Wilmer
Valderrama but unlike a lot of Netflix
productions it's been met with little
critical acclaim and hasn't attracted
the kind of cult audience enjoyed by
many of the streaming services other
original series FFPs another hindrance
the koutris film career is ironically
his off screen success he moonlights as
a tech developer an investor which has
become a serious ii work life for him
and he basically helped put Twitter on
the map by engaging at a popularity
contest on the platform with national
news station CNN in 2009
Plus let's face it he tends to make more
headlines for his personal life than his
on-screen
kricher and his first wife give me more
were regular characters on the red
carpet and used their social network
platforms the document virtually every
detail of the marriage and he in a
second wife mila kunis continue to
attract off-camera attention making
people were decision people yeah
even his audiences avoid Kutcher's films
a lot of people still take the time to
speculate on what the couple will name
the children not that he doesn't give
them plenty of reasons to play along I
there was a rallying cry from a
collective that believed in the name
Hawkeye Hawkeye I'm an Iowan yet I got a
name Hawkeye is like mash like he could
be a doctor maybe the two should go
ahead and just make that fake moonquake
lake movie from Annie with Rihanna after
all of it
turn things around for it what if we go
to the moon to an x-ray or something
good night design but I will catch you I
know it's time thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to